I this is the third type of cable and
the most expensive and the most advanced
okay fiber optics okay now sir I should
come back and ask the question first how
do fiber optic cables avoid these
problems altogether okay we will explore
that and then I want you to say tell me
okay despite the fact that they're going
to be so awesome
why haven't they are you know replaced
UTB or coaxial cable is the most popular
kind of cable so I think about those two
questions number one how does this which
is a it's a piece of glass okay and it's
very thin by the way how does it
overcome the policy you talking about
yeah good okay so the the reason why we
had all this probably interference and
all that right is because oh sorry wrong
one electricity of magnetism interact
with each other okay
now light does interact with magnetism
okay because if you have a strong enough
magnetic field well you know just
anything but it won't produce a magnetic
field and it won't get sort of altered
by magnetic field it'll just get moved
around okay so when you have a look at
this what you can see is light
propagating through this is glass okay
now this is actually a lot thicker than
a normal piece of optic fiber normal
optical is about on the thinness of a
human hair okay so insanely thin but the
reason I picked up this image because it
demonstrates the same concept okay so
what isn't pinging straight through the
optic fiber okay
instead it's bouncing off all the walls
if you like okay and when you think
about it that makes sense because optic
fiber is not necessarily always in
straight lines okay it's actually going
to be bouncing a lot if it's curved or
something like that okay
so that's really sweet no problems
without electromagnetic interference so
why have an optic fibers taken over and
gone everywhere yeah okay number one so
this is there's more than one reason
okay this is optic fiber
and you'll see it spell both ways
by the way like English way and American
Way idea really matters number one
expense it turns out that making glass
which is as thin as a human hair is not
that easy here's a very costly process
okay it has to be very precise as well
can't just be thin
it's got to be exact okay what else what
else what other reasons there ah good so
it's fragile right okay because glass is
shattered
we're very easily right now there are
things that can be done to optic fiber
to reduce that but it's still an issue
yeah excellent this is actually probably
the big reason optic vibe is great you
know Electra mania interference doesn't
really come into the picture but you
know what most of us don't really mind
have you been electromagnetic
interference okay so all these Ethernet
cables are running around the room they
do the job just fine even though they're
this sort of arm this low tech side run
this low tech technology okay
it still works it's much cheaper it does
the job importantly it's over a short
distance okay so what we would have is
you'd use this over short distances and
where the data is not super super
critically important okay you would use
this over longer distances and also if
you're running past lots of things that
are made of metal okay because they're
going to interfere with your
electromagnet and then lastly use optic
fiber when you really need to make sure
you can get your data safely when you go
bring very very long distances okay and
where you have a lot of data to transmit
so if you remember when we're talking
about network infrastructure okay we
talked about this idea called a backbone
remember that
what's a backbone
we compare it to the spine right let's
go backward right the idea is there are
parts of the network that are going to
get much more traffic than others so
it's not like a highway right
well most backbones are made of fiber
optics okay because they can transmit a
lot more data a lot more reliably okay